Yeah,
I had,
I had an incident,
uh,
on a,
on the airplane going to Indianapolis.
Where this,
this guy like,
I don't know,
I just started like interrogating me.
He thought it was some sort of flight
risk about what,
I dunno,
he was on something.
I don't know what happened.
Like I was sitting down.
So he's just a passenger.
Yeah.
And I was,
I didn't know if he was a sky marshal,
but he,
he ordered a doers in the beginning and
he just slammed it.
[inaudible] so I'm like,
this guy's not a scar.
My Sky Marshal,
this guy's boozing it up.
So he just goes to me,
he's like,
Eh,
which is sitting there and he just says,
he goes,
hey you,
are you afraid to fly?
And I'm like,
what?
He goes,
are you afraid of flag?
Oh No,
I'm not afraid to fly.
And he goes,
you sure?
Cause you know it's okay.
You can tell me if you are immediately,
I'm looking at this guy.
What do you mean?
It's like,
okay,
what is this like interrogation one o
one,
build a relationship with your subject
thing that you're doing here.
And I was just like,
no.
He goes,
dude.
all right cause you know,
he just kind of fidgeting and looking
around.
I was like,
no man.
I go,
I'm cool.
He's like,
oh you like to fly.
I'm like,
what?
I'm up here cause he don't,
I bumped myself up and going on back
there.
I don't like it.
And then he goes,
he's all right.
You know,
but you know you,
you can tell me if you're afraid to fly.
So now I'm just like,
dude,
I'm not afraid to fly.
So,
and he's staring at me and I put my hand
like this to show that it wasn't
shaking.
I go,
I'm not nervous.
All right,
thanks for asking.
And then he goes,
well,
anybody can do that.
And I'm just like,
oh Jesus Christ.
And I just said,
look dude,
I'm drinking water.
You're drinking doers.
Okay.
And he goes,
that wasn't doers,
right.
And I'm just like,
I fucked this guy.
So I'm sitting there.
He,
you saw a mortar it,
huh?
You saw him order doers.
I was sitting and he said,
let me get a doors.
And she brought her over neat and he
threw it back like he was drinking
baby's milk.
What's impressive is this guy's old
school starting off good,
right?
So then there's like five minutes of
silence,
more passages are getting on,
and then the guy goes,
hey,
you know,
I'm sorry man,
I just got off on a,
on the wrong foot there.
Right?
He goes,
my name is so and so.
What's your name?
Asked me what my name is.
And I was thinking of saying something
like,
Steve,
you know,
and uh,
I wish I need Clark.
I wish I said some silly name,
you know,
but I didn't think of when I just went,
it's bill.
And he goes,
okay.
He goes up.
Why?
Why are you going to Indianapolis Bill?
He started doing the shit and I just
look at the guy and I go,
I'm like,
yeah,
I don't have to answer your questions.
Whoa,
I don't,
he has no fucking authority.
You're not a sky marshal.
You're drinking booze,
you're an asshole.
What are you want?
Are you afraid to fly?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Leave me alone.
Right?
So then he goes like,
all right,
now,
now I'm concerned.
Okay,
I am concerned.
why are you going to Indianapolis Bill,
right?
He says,
is this right?
And they closed the doors and that
they're doing all this stuff.
And I just,
I just start like,
I joked to my podcasts,
I just started smirking like Ryan
Gosling,
you know,
he does that little Mona Lisa smile.
We just kind of smile and I'm just
sitting there shaking my head at the
guy,
right?
And I'm literally taking out my eye
pillow.
I wear like a mask just to say,
I'm so not worried about anything that
you're going to fucking do all this
passive aggressive,
shift this to piss this guy off.
And he's go,
why are you going to Indianapolis Belt?
And I just just kept,
I didn't say anything to him.
I just kept laughing,
just kept shaking my head and um,
was taxiing down.
And he goes,
dude,
he goes,
I fucking do this for a fucking living
such ffffound and all this stuff.
The lady in front turns around,
starts looking at what?
Taxi down the thing because you don't
answer my questions right now.
I'm going to hit that call button.
I will hit that call button.
I will stop this plane and you will be
fucking arrested like saying all this
stuff and I'm just looking at him
smiling,
shaking my head,
like,
go ahead and push it,
dude.
Let's see where the fuck this goes
through the Hilarious,
what happens?
Does the pilot come out?
There's a police car pull up to the
play.
No fucking clue.
So he goes to push it and you can't find
it.
It was kind of a weird place and he
finally finds it.
He hit the button.
I'm like,
oh,
he fuck,
he hit the button.
This is hilarious.
And I'm just sitting there.
He goes,
now you wait,
you fucking wait,
blah blah blah.
And I'm just sitting there smiling,
shaking my head at him.
I'm like,
dude,
I don't care.
I don't get you're,
you're not.
You have no fucking authority.
You're not going to hit me.
You're not going to do anything.
You're on fucking something.
But I'm not getting that dude.
If that guy had a vibe like he's going
to punch me,
I would have been up in the,
in the house.
But he didn't.
He just had like that.
It was like a kid throwing a temper
tantrum.
He wanted like this,
you want to seem like he wanted to be an
army ranger,
but he didn't quite make it or what'd he
look like?
He was like a,
why are we doing in good shape?
You know why Redo white dude,
that dude who shot that Trayvon Martin
kid who wasn't really a cop.
Yeah,
but he wanted to be a cop so he took it
to the next level and it's the same.
I could have squashed the whole thing
and just been like,
look,
I'm a comedian,
but I'm going to Indianapolis.
If you'd like to come out to the show,
I could have done that,
but I'm a dick and I hate,
I hate fucking,
I hate authority and this guy doesn't
have any,
so fuck him.
So I just laugh now he pushes the
button.
So then the stewardess comes over and
she goes,
yeah,
what's the problem?
He goes to sky is a flight risk.
I am not comfortable flying with him,
but Baba Baba,
Baba and all the shit.
I was surprised how few people were
looking around.
People were just kind of sitting there
and this guy was wigging out and I'm
just sitting there and then the
stewardess was like,
all right,
did anybody else see any behavior?
And The lady was sitting in front of
him,
pointed at him and said,
yeah,
he was berating any point and she
pointed me,
he,
he was berating him and I'm just like,
perfect.
So I'm literally putting my fucking ims
down as I'm talking to him just going,
hey,
I'm just a guy trying to go in
Indianapolis.
This guy's drinking doers and he's
dropping the F bomb.
Then I'm thinking,
fuck.
I said bomb,
you know,
prominent and there wasn't a problem and
this guy is just doing this thing where
he wants to win.
He wants some sort of recognition of
what,
whatever the fuck he thinks he is still
moving.
No.
At this point it fucking stopped.
It pulled over.
I forgot that part.
It pulled over and stopped.
Dude,
it's a fucking red eye.
Okay.
It stops.
Another stewards comes over and he goes,
what's the problem?
And he goes through the whole fucking
thing.
And then in the end it's like basically
the captain at this point is going,
do I really have to come back there?
It's like really the red eye fucking
flight.
My last flight of the day I used to fly
combat missions,
you know,
fucking boring.
This is to fly this fucking bus.
I don't want to deal with this bullshit.
Do I really have to come back there?
And then they finally asked him,
I said,
hey,
are you going to be comfortable flying
with this guy?
And He,
uh,
I think they acknowledged that he had
some sort of something there.
So cause you know what,
knowing that it's okay,
it's gonna be okay,
just put whatever,
right.
That he had some sort of,
something like some sort of power that
like they checked with him,
like,
you're going to stand down sir,
like to whatever s fucking spy he
thought he was.
So now we get back in line and we're
taxing.
And as we're going down the runway,
I got my eye thing on and I'm just
sitting there and he's yapping in my
ear.
He goes,
you think this is fucking over?
You think this is fucking over.
And under this point I'm laughing.
I'm holding my stomach in a fucking
laughing and it's driving them nuts and
I'm having a fucking ball with this guy.
And he goes,
uh,
you know,
my dad's,
the CEO is some fucking company in
Indianapolis.
And he starts saying that he's going to
have me fucking arrested when I land.
And uh,
and he starts describing the view I was
going to see from the jail,
like some law and order.
Oh,
you're going to let you get a picture of
this photo.
Take a photo.
Now,
how could you not just have been filming
video this whole entire time?
That would be amazing.
You can,
can't you just be in the moment and not
turn into a film?
Crew story's even better.
The universe gave me this fucking
moment.
I'm telling this story.
I don't,
I don't know.
So he fucking,
uh,
so then I got my thanks down and then he
finally,
he's,
yeah,
he's going.
Yeah,
he,
Oh,
you gonna love the view from the jail.
You can see Lucas oil field and blah,
blah,
and all this shit.
And then he finds oil.
That's where the colts play this view.
Dude.
It was such,
such hacky interrogation.
Then he finally said a,
he goes,
you know what?
I'm glad.
You know what?
I fucking hope you do something.
We're up there and I'm fucking burst.
It was not sitting there with a
blindfold on laughing at him.
It was driving him fucking nuts.
It was great.
So then five minutes of silence,
10 minutes of silence goes by and I'm
finally thinking that maybe this shit's
over or is he just sitting there staring
at the side of my head and then all of a
sudden I just hear it right as I'm
starting to nod off,
I just hear why you're going to
Indianapolis Bill.
And I just laugh.
So do my adrenaline was fucking going.
I was just like,
wow,
they're going to stop the plane.
This is fucking intense man.
This is crazy.
What's going to happen?
And I'm totally innocent so I got to
kind of watch it happen.
So then I couldn't sleep.
So I was sitting there with that stupid
mask on for like a half an hour and then
files just like,
all right,
fuck it,
I got to take it off and I got to deal
with this guy and I take it off and I
look over and he's just teach this
passed out head hanging this fucking,
you know,
special ops guy.
You know you should really passed out.
You should fucking way Liam with a huge
haymaker right in the face and then
immediately pretend you're asleep.
No now cause someone would have said
that,
someone would have seen that.
So now you know what I did was I
immediately started pounding waters
cause I didn't have to go to the
bathroom and I wanted to get up on the
play and just to see if he was going to
fucking wig out again.
It makes them sort of thing.
So you go to the bathroom.
I started slamming
would have water in your,
I have to go to full of fucking
bathroom.
Like you can't believe in this fucking
guy's passed out.
He's now,
I held it for the last hour.
He didn't wake up until we landed.
And then we pulled up to the terminal
and I got out and I stood up and he
wouldn't look at me and I'm thinking how
he probably slept it off and I was
feeling fucking weird,
hopefully.
And The lady in front of me got up and
she just goes,
she smiled and she said,
hey.
And I just said,
and I was like,
oh,
that was,
that was an interesting one.
And then he had the pillow like this,
Joe,
he hit it behind here in some weird
position in,
in some sort of like Alpha male way.
He tried to get some sort of tough
thing.
The last word,
he took the pillow out and he threw it
down the hint by between his legs and he
like grunted even like,
like he threw a pill down.
That was it.
That was my trip to Indianapolis.
Oh.
And then I worked at a theater and Elmo
was there.